and actually some of you do know each
other coach and michael you've worked
together yeah we did the good fight
together we spent a whole season
together yeah michael and i two brits
playing two americans on a big american
i was bearded then oh okay
back in the days when i was bearded yes
different color hair different color
beard a whole different person it's
almost like you were acting
this is the follow-up to the good wife
this is the good fight yes yes and it
must be weird being
brits on set when it's all americans all
around you why is that weird
it's really nice when another brit shows
up because there's always a slight
there's a language barrier i mean i'm
sure you may have noticed this with some
of us no you guys have a way of saying
things certain terms you use that we
don't use the same and our scripts are
full of these terms i don't know if you
even remember this story about the
hummer do you remember this story ahama
bahama i think i was a bit confused
about what a hammer was so we were in a
scene where michael was playing a really
nasty perverted um dirty eve
god he was so good at it
he found this guy and he was kind of
demanding and i want my home i want my
9am hammer all the time and we both
assumed in this well we just assumed
that he was talking about a kind of
old-fashioned long limo and michael was
like well he can't be that bad i mean
he's just demanding a long car i mean i
don't know what's so bad about this guy
and then the crew kept laughing each
time you did it and then when we
finished you were like what is a hummer
what is a hummer and they would like to
[ __ ]
i've been asking for the wrong thing
[Applause]
[Music]